[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive du département c'est parti pour
le sommaire rugby les airs a réalisé une
très belle opération ce week-end en
championnat de fédérale 2 en s'imposant
contre domo à domicile victoire qui
permet au club de s'éloigner de la zone
de relégation les détails dans cette
édition
badminton un rendez-vous 100% féminin
était programmé au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour faire
découvrir cette discipline à des
débutantes reportage a su dans quelques
instants
escrime lui en quoi organiser une grande
compétition pour les 13-14 ans ce
dimanche matin objectif préparer la
nouvelle génération aux jeux olympiques
de 2024
nous étions sur place pour recueillir à
les réactions et puis nous parlerons
également dans la coupe gambardella en
fin d'émission le club de
voisins-le-bretonneux est encore en lice
pour cette coupe de france des jeunes et
jouera à ce week-end son match les
avants de parler football nous allons
parler à rugby
[Musique]
on commence donc par du rugby la 10e
journée du championnat de fédérale 2
dans la poule une plaisir réalisé une
très bonne opération dans la lutte pour
le maintien les plaisirs oies se sont
imposés 24 à 8 à domicile contre un
adversaire direct domont leur deuxième
victoire de la saison classement cette
performance permet aux yvelinois de
sortir de la zone rouge et de compter
six points d'avancé sur le premier
relégable des résultats obtenus grâce au
travail de toute l'équipe selon
sébastien roch à lille l'entraîneur donc
de l'équipe on écoute tout va beaucoup
plus vite on est on est plus précis sur
ce qu'on fait on n'est plus maîtrisée on
perd beaucoup moins de ballons contact
voilà maintenant depuis le début d'année
on travaille énormément tout notre
conquête donc c'est pareil ça plutôt
dans le bon sens sa province plutôt bien
du rugby encore nous allons descendre de
deux divisions pour parler à de la
division honneur et plus précisément de
versailles le club était considéré début
septembre comme l'un des favoris pour la
montée en fédérale 3 mais verset se
classe à l'heure actuelle à 3e du
championnat à la 7e journée
les ambitions sont elles remises en
cause pour répondre à cette question
nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président éric tournier l'entraîneur
alain à jamin et le vice capitaine
damien verstraete
bonsoir alors comment jugez vous le
début de saison de versailles président
écoutez plutôt correct correct pourquoi
parce que sur sept matches on en a
remporté cinq dont elle a perdu deux
dont un qu'on n'aurait pas dû perdre
il est vrai que face à un groupe comme
qui à sarcelles dans notre
face à nous sarcelles est une grosse
équipe il est vrai qu'il ya peu de
chances qu'on puisse arriver à leur
niveau en fin de saison
donc notre objectif il est clair la
remontée toujours maintenant sans doute
en place deux ou trois ans tout casser
nos objectifs voilà vous disiez
sarcelles quasiment impossible à aller
chercher on peut le dire ils ont déjà
sept victoires en sept matchs et neuf
points d'avancé sur vous qui est
troisième
et ils nous ont battus fit également
26,18 chez vous oui nous battre chez
nous avons fait une entame
catastrophique
on est à 20 à 20 6 à la mi temps ont
fait prendre deux essais casquette
blanche une très belle deuxième mi temps
on n'est pas si loin on n'est pas si
loin que ça pour me dépasser à deux mais
c'est sur ce match-là y avait pas grand
chose à dire sur la première mi temps
après c'est vrai qu'ils sont moins de
vent on va s'accrocher championnat c'est
long oui mais après ils vont gagner à
bagneux il gagna vitryat une chez nous
enfin sur les 4 premiers gagnent à 1,3
fois l'extérieur donc ils ont un
calendrier favorable sur le match retour
après on sait jamais on va pas lâcher le
va pas lâcher le championnat est plié
sur vous damien plier non sinon sinon
seraient pas là et on arrêterait jeu de
s'entraîner voilà comme l'a dit alain
sur un match on joue jamais 80 minutes
comme les sept cas sur sarcelles à
chevreuse et qu'un jour pareil
la première mi temps joue pas on joue
qu'une mi temps donc ça va être
compliqué de gagner un match et on
continue comme ça donc ils glissaient
matin le plus faucon taille est plus
direct pour gagner un maximum de matchs
est ce que ça vous motive encore plus
justement cette rivalité avec sarcelles
de voir une équipe qui gagne tous ses
matches est ce que ça vous motive encore
plus à gagner tous vos matches depuis le
début de l'année on veut gagner tous nos
matches apprécierait de voir une belle
équipe comme ça ça donne envie de les
rassembler sur certains points
apprennent aussi à versailles en est
belle équipe on sait mettre en chose de
mettre en place de bonnes choses
voilà c'est vrai que voir une équipe
comme ça se balader plus ou moins dans
ce championnat c'est vrai que ça donne
envie
éric tournier vous pensez que ça va les
motiver encore plus les joueurs sur la
deuxième partie de saison
aller chercher cette montée oui parce
qu'on a l'effectif en fait il faut pas
oublier qu'on a une réserve qui qui
marche très très bien avec beaucoup de
joueurs
la saison est longue je pense
honnêtement qu'on a un groupe qui il l'a
fallu son a eu beaucoup de recrutements
donc il a fallu de trois matchs pour
équilibrer l'entraîneur luc les coaches
font un énorme boulot et je pense que ça
va payer sur la fin de saison et
commence à passer l'ambiance au sein du
vestiaire
bien bien ces groupes compétiteur quand
même avec du caractère
sur les biens de faire un bloc de trois
matches trois victoires en étant mené à
chaque fois notamment à melun on est à
14 en deuxième mi temps on va chercher
la victoire en fin de match on lâche pas
donc voilà un groupe qui fait preuve de
caractère c'est assez nouveau je pense
du côté de versailles
mais après il fallait aussi trouver
trouver un équilibre il ya une émulation
et de la concurrence certains le vivent
bien d'autres un peu moins bien donc
c'est de management qu'il faut jouer sur
ces leviers
mais concrètement il ya vraiment un
super groupe super état d'esprit groupe
vit bien
dames en dehors du terrain il n'y avait
pas assez de joueurs on peut le dire a
pour l'équipe une
mais finalement cette année vous avez le
choix ouais il y avait moins de
profondeur de banc enfin il y avait une
bonne paie déjà la saison dernière parce
que de me filer jusqu'à la transe quand
même faut le faire quoi vainqueur du
paiement des charges ile-de-france mais
en profondeur de banc c'était un peu
moins de trois blessures à des postes
clés et on était un peu dépourvu alors
que cette année on peut pas lié à ça
donc c'est pour ça je vous dis on va pas
lâcher le morceau et puis puis ils ont
tous je pense préparer les phases
finales je pénètre france puisqu'on peut
jouer cette montée si on finit pas
premier de poule sur les faces freinage
sur notre france qui est aujourd'hui je
pense l'objectif voilà le credo du club
oui parce que sercel est quand même très
loin même si là on va pas lâcher on y
croit on aura peut-être aller moins de
pression mais ça va être compliqué hein
pas m'installer là d'aller les chercher
président damien faire strates fait
partie de cette équipe en tant que vice
capitaine
est-ce que
voilà vous compter sur un joueur comme
comme damien pour mettre à bien un
projet de club d'amiens est un fruit de
la formation du rcv clairement c'est un
vrai versailles et on en a beaucoup dans
l'équipe même si on a fait du
recrutement mais relatif on sait plus
vraiment sur ben ono junior nos balandra
naudé bélascain auparavant en avoir 29
familiale on a un club familial mais
surtout formateur puisque on a quand
même toutes les sélections qui sont qui
jouent dans les meilleurs
compétition donc oui on a on a vraiment
un club qui va aller dans la profession
intégré dans l'équipe senior les
versaillais damien on est un produit
fier d'ailleurs qu'il soit le vice
capitaine ça m'étonne pas il n'aurait pu
avoir d'autres ça c'est le choix de
l'entraîneur
avec des joueurs qui viennent de
l'extérieur mais qui ont très bien
intégré le club donc vraiment un bon
état d'esprit un gros groupe
donc j'ai eu bien sûr fier que ce soir
en plus un vice-capitaine verstraete
vous êtes du coup en division honneur
depuis deux saisons c'est la deuxième
saison cette année
est-ce qu'il faut encore une saison
supplémentaire pour créer une émulation
dans l'équipe
attendre que l'équipe soit à maturité où
il faut tout de suite monté dès l'année
prochaine
valider l'objectif depuis 2006 on sait
la montée après c'est vrai que
l'ossature et l'équipe qu'on a est
stable depuis quelques années comme
disait alain eric tout à l'heure on
s'est fait on s'est fait renforcer sur
des postes clés je pense que cette année
c'est la bonne année
on y croit on est tous encore motivé
pour le faire elle sait pas si ce sera
l'année prochaine mais en tout cas on a
tous en tête la montée en fédérale 1
trop pour la faune très rapidement on a
monté très haut l'idée c'est ça assez de
plus rapidement possible et qui peut
encore s'améliorer selon vous à alain
jammes un oui très clairement oui c'est
une marge de progression
une marge de progression surtout
fasquelle a signalé c'est ce caractère
le groupe fait preuve de caractère pour
les chercher ces victoires qui ont pas
été simple a notamment contre journaux
chez nous et dernier match on est menés
13-0 à la 50e minute et aux normes et 20
points quoi donc voilà c'est un petit
peu la marge de progression mais je
pense qu on est à 50 60 % je pense que
les gars peuvent être encore plus
compétiteur et voilà c'était cet esprit
de la gagne qu'il faut qu'il faut savoir
sur tous les matchs pour rien lâcher
pour rester au contact et encore une
fois l'objectif c'est vraiment préparer
à gagner pour pour aller très loin en
quatre ans quoi pour aller chercher
cette montée et ça ça passe dès dimanche
prochain soit un match très important à
mains nues merci à tous les trois d'être
passé sur ce plat chaud c'est pour nous
parler du club de versailles et de la
montée on vous souhaite de réaliser de
grosses performances sur la deuxième
partie de saison et de montée en fin de
saison
merci à tous les 3 6 6 1 au monde
handball à présent décidément le club de
montigny le bretonneux n'y arrive pas
dans le championnat de nationale 2
lésigny montrent elles ont concédé leur
sixième défaite de la saison dans leur
gymnase pierre de coubertin contre
conflans le score final 25 à 26 une
défaite qui condamne montillot
bretonneau à la dernière place du
championnat à quatre points du premier
non relégable le club devra se reprendre
dès samedi prochain sur le terrain du
havre à l'occasion de la 8e journée du
championnat sports de raquettes à
présent une fois n'est pas coutume nous
allons parler de badminton c'était une
première un rendez-vous 100% féminin est
organisée ce samedi au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines en
partenariat avec le comité a
départementale l'objectif était de
promouvoir ce sport auprès du public
débutant programme des matchs et du
findel et du fitness pour apprendre les
déplacements des images de nicolas
d'ombrie en fait parce que tu tape juste
devant facteur vraiment d'ailleurs j'ai
peur de me faire mal clémence brenier 22
ans redécouvre les bases du badminton au
vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines
la débutante s'est inscrite avec une
amie ce samedi de descendre à
l'événement bad au féminin organisé pour
la première fois dans la structure ça
avait l'air d'être un bon moment qui est
une initiation au badminton se passe un
sport qu'on a tous fait je pense au
collège et c'est un peu
c'est pas forcément du haut niveau tout
ça et je pense que j'avais envie de
découvrir un peu plus ce sport
clémence fait partie des 23 joueurs qui
se sont inscrits pour ce rendez-vous
objectif annoncé de l'événement pousser
les femmes à s'inscrire le badminton
compte plus de 6000 y sont si dans les
yvelines mais reste encore
confidentielle au niveau féminin
le bad féminin représente un quart de ce
chiffre là donc à l'idée c'est de
vraiment essayé de donner les femmes à
faire du badminton est un sport
accessible à tous pour rendre
l'initiation encore plus conviviale
écoute j'avais organisé un fit mine
tonnes pendant une trentaine de minutes
le but après les déplacements au rythme
de la musique
si on bat 2000 d'annoncer pas se
déplacer on va difficilement pouvoir
être intense où les volants c'est un jeu
où on essaye de mettre en crise d'autant
toujours l'adversaire et du coup pour le
mettre en crise de temps on va essayer
de jouer là où il n'est pas et pour ça
il va falloir se déplacer le plus
rapidement possible et c'est toute une
sorte de jeu d'appui voilà qu'il faut
passer par un apprentissage et du coup
c'est en apprentissage le film in time
qui permet d'être beaucoup plus ludique
après le succès rencontré cette année
une deuxième édition devrait être
organisée l'année prochaine au mois de
décembre
toujours au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines nous allons à
présent prendre la direction de
guyancourt le cercle escrime de la ville
organisée ce dimanche au gymnase maurice
baquet une grande compétition baptisée
horizon à 2024 objectif accompagner à
les futurs champions de demain le rendez
vous a attiré 33 participants âgés de 13
à 14 ans a les images sont signés à
nicolas landry le montage est déjà là
ils ont entre 13 et 14 ans ils seront
peut-être aux jeux olympiques de paris
en 2024 pour les aider à progresser le
club de gueugnon co organisait ce
dimanche 3 dès son origine as more is
back un tournoi baptisé horizon 2024 au
total 33 jeunes avec des rêves plein la
tête ont participé à ce rendez vous
j'aimerais bien y aller et j'aimerais
bien aussi gagner aussi mais d'abord
faut gagner cette compétition là j'aurai
moins de chance en or et en 2024
cette compétition qualificative pour les
championnats de france a surtout permis
à ces jeunes pépites venues de toute
l'île de france de peaufiner leurs
techniques de combat hausse à savoir
quand est-ce que l'adversaire va faire
basculer déjà ça serait bien attaquer
attaquer au bon moment attaqué trop tôt
je m'adapte en fonction de ce qu'ils
font s'ils vont plus faire des attaques
j'aime et à la défense circulent bah je
vais aller à l'attack ce dimanche chaque
participant a pu prendre part une
dizaine de combats mais le chemin vers
une médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
est encore long selon les coachs et a
quand même beaucoup de travail on verra
s'ils arrivent à a progressé à continuer
à leur progression tout au long de leur
vie d'escrimeur et puis faut les
accompagner il faut voir là
actuellement c'est difficile à dire
parce que c'est quand on est quand même
assez loin mais elle travaille à faire
c'est sûr et il ya du potentiel au cid
d'autres tournois seront organisés à
guyancourt d'ici 2024 pour former cette
nouvelle génération la mairie le club
local ont signé un partenariat
on passe maintenant notre rubrique
agenda
[Musique]
avant de passer à l'agenda du week-end
hameau de la coupe de france de football
où il y au club de r3 réussi à se
qualifier pour les 32e de finale de la
coupe de france ce samedi en venant à
bout de l'ess matoury une équipe qui
évolue en r1 deux divisions au dessus
des yvelinois le score 2 buts à 1 on
regarde la réaction des joueurs à
l'issue du match
des superbes images de joie ils
connaîtront leur adversaire ce soir aux
alentours de 19 heures 30 les joueurs
ont déjà annoncé vouloir jouer week-end
du 6 janvier prochain contre un club de
ligue 1 et si possible le paris
saint-germain on continue à parler de
football et de la coupe de france des
jeunes et plus précisément des moins de
19 ans la coupe gambardella le club de
voisins-le-bretonneux a réussi l'exploit
de se hisser au premier tour fédéral ils
affronteront ce week-end le fc ouest
tourangeaux à l'extérieur à quelques
jours de l'une des plus belles pages de
l'histoire du club nous avons la chance
de recevoir sur ce plateau à
l'entraîneur christian thomas le
capitaine de l'équipe vincent à berton
et le gardien de but de l'équipe mathias
henry bonsoir
enfin c'est l'un des matches les plus
beaux de l'histoire du club les plus
importants peut-être de l'histoire du
club
oui important oui parce que c'est une
belle aventure après il faut rester
concession le championnat c'est le
produit le sait la montée en d1 l'année
prochaine donc il faut vraiment qu'on
reste quand même concentré là c'est un
truc à part pour les joueurs c'est une
belle aventure pour le club ça fait
parler du club
que des bonnes choses mais font ça nous
ont beaucoup d'énergie c'est à dire bah
les joueurs là ils sont obnubilés par la
gambardella
ils ont que ça en tête donc là après
c'est dur de
pour les championnats comme la dimanche
c'est un match important qu'on a perdu
oakley donc après voilà on a grillé un
joker mais comment fait on pour les
garder concentrés
bref on est on en est c'est de leur dire
priorité championnat après elle à la con
par dallas viendra après chaque chaque
chose en son temps
mais là c'est ça faire fait sens au
niveau des joueurs quoi c'est compliqué
est-ce que vous avez ce sentiment là
vous à vincent que vous faites
il est par cette coupe gambardella
on essaie de rester concentré mais c'est
compliqué quand on a un match qu'on va
jouer à côté de tours c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué de se concentrer sur le
championnat même si c'est bon on essaye
quand même vous déjà imaginé arriver à
ce stade de la compétition
quand vous avez débuté cette coupe
gambardella non pas du tout pas du tout
on n'imaginait pas du tout parce que
c'est déjà ce n'était jamais arrivé dans
l'histoire du club et on pensait pas
qu'on pourrait le faire et on y arrive
et mathias vous avez le sentiment vous
marquer l'histoire du club
vraiment les grands vous en avons parlé
les seniors ils ont félicité tout
d'abord et je pense que oui c'est une
grande page de l'histoire du club si ce
tournoi parce que ça n'a jamais été fait
avant
on a vraiment marqué marc est cool c'est
une surprise vraiment de voir le club à
ce niveau là va web après moi je connais
mes joueurs ça fait depuis les u15 que
je les suis donc j'ai monté avec à
chaque fois je l'écris dans chaque
catégorie gt suivi donc ça fait quatre
ans qu'on se connaît on a à peu près le
même groupe
ils sont issus tous la plupart du centre
et qui sont issus du club ça fait entrer
9 10 ans qui sont depuis les 8 u 9 si
son horizon au club donc on travaille
sur le long terme et wes à chalais qu'on
pouvait faire des choses je connais le
groupe et il ya de la qualité
on est monté la dernière en excellence
avec les u17 l'a donc et la gestion u19
et je sais que je savais qu'on pouvait
faire quelque chose après après on a eu
un peu de chance au tirage
ça fait partie aussi de la de la
réussite
et puis le dernier tour on a quand même
a été gagné à saint maur qui évolue deux
divisions au dessus
un exploit en exploits et pourquoi pas
encore dimanche créer la surprise
vous pensez que c'est
cette cohésion des équipes qui fait la
force justement de voisins cette année
je pense que le fait que les gens les
jeunes que les joueurs se connaissent
depuis un bout de temps il s'entend très
bien il ya une bonne ambiance fait qu'
il ya de la qualité aussi
depuis quatre ans qu on arrive que je
suis arrivé au club ça travaille ça
progresse donc on fait tout pour que
que ça a marché voilà je pense que
dimanche c'est du 50-50 et voit en tant
qu'entraîneur vous avez donné une
importance particulière à cette coupe
gambardella toujours pas toujours pas
non là ça va commencer à partir de
mercredi à l'entraînement je veux pas
parce que je sais que si je commence
trop à parler de ça ils sont déjà dans
leur tête
si on part en plus le samedi ont fait un
déplacement donc ça va être un truc sur
deux jours donc là les joueurs et ils
ont jamais connu ça donc
donc non non chaque chose en son temps
là on a fini le dimanche maintenant et à
partir de demain mercredi entraînement
on va commencer à vraiment parler de du
match de dimanche
alors vous avez éliminé epinay sur orge
aux tirs au but au deuxième tour sa mort
également lors du dernier tour de la
finale régionale l'équipe a du mental on
peut le dire vous avez sentiment là vous
aussi du côté des ja oui parce qu'on a
été menés enfin on a ils sont revenus à
égalité deux fois à saint maur donc à
chaque fois on a pu surmonter ça quoi
jusqu'à arriver au penalty et gagner le
match
il ya deux gardiens c'est vous qui avait
qualifié l'équipe du coup sûr ces deux
tours
oui j'y ai contribué est-ce qu'on vous
avez travaillé particulièrement les noms
et les tirs au but à l'entraînement nous
pas du tout on a fait juste contre saint
maur le vendredi exceptionnellement on a
fait une séance on s'est dit bon ouais
parce que je trouve que tu as on appelle
un terrain d'entraînement les joueurs
peuvent remettre 10 sur 10 et après avec
la pression de l'émotion du moment
le dimanche n'est jamais pareil mais on
l'est on la travaille et je pense qu'on
va leur faire vendredi on sait jamais ça
nous a bien réussi
donc voilà on va garder habitude donc
vous travaillez pas particulièrement
l'effet n'est pas du tout et comment
abordez-vous du coup ce match de ce
week-end contre le fc ouest tourangeau
c'est une équipe où je connaissais pas
du tout je comprends bien ouais on la
connaît pas du tout déjà parce que ça
n'évolue pas dans
dans notre division ni dans notre dans
notre région
donc on va l'aborder sans trop se mettre
de pression parce qu'on est déjà arrivé
à un stade où on pensait pas déjà
pouvoir y arriver
du coup c'est que du bonus à partir de
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter dans cette coupe de france
le président de france des jeunes
horaire de base surtout bava d'aller
faire un bon match surtout se faire
plaisir
c'est sa plus important après un match
reste un match
moi je pense que on a la qualité pour se
qualifier et au cas où viendra bien
qu'on reçoit la maison parce qu'on fait
beaucoup ont fait beaucoup de
déplacements
ça serait la cerise sur le gâteau que
voilà en face à un truc bien au club et
pourquoi pas à 100 de formation vous
êtes déjà imaginé avec la coupe dans les
bras non pas du tout non je pense
qu'avant dire d'avoir la peau dans les
mains font passer par beaucoup de
l'équipe à battre
je pense beaucoup plus contre innovant
vous garder la tête sur les épaules si
je comprends bien les piles et chupa
faut pas dire ça l'entraîneur parce que
sinon il va nous rappeler le championnat
et vous mettra remplaçant oui la
prochain match comme moi je pense alors
avant de se quitter
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur le tirage
de la coupe du monde 2018 qui s'est
déroulé en russie à vendredi dernier la
france a hérité du père ou du danemark
et de l'australie des adversaires plutôt
accessible on peut le dire pour pour les
bleus qu'en pensez vous outre cette
table pour moi c'est un bon tirage on
suppose se met trop de pression
après ici ils devraient pour moi finir
premier facilement premier facilement
pareil pour vous mais paris c'est un
meilleur tirage qu'on puisse avoir je
pense meilleur tirage l'australie non ça
fait pas peur
danemark non plus la france est favorite
de la coupe du monde sur vous
à fait à les prétendantes on va dire
parce qu'il ya quand même du monde
l'allemagne brésil mais peu après dans
le dernier carré oui c'est possible
c'est possible dans les cars également
indiqué quoi qu'il arrive c'est non
seulement alors je vous rappelle que la
france préparera la coupe du monde à
clairefontaine dans les yvelines avant
de rejoindre leur camp de base en russie
à partir du mois de juin
vous allez essayer d'avoir des
autographes peut-être avec la fontaine
n'ont pas les outils simples
déplacements d'abord offert déplacement
à clairefontaine saxe est
alors merci à tous les trous en tout cas
dépasser sur ce plateau et bon courage
pour votre match de dimanche on souhaite
de continuer à écrire un peu plus
l'histoire du club
merci en plus de la coupe gambardella il
y aura du basket ce week-end trappe
affrontera à domicile oreilles ce samedi
soir à 20 heures au gymnase paul mallet
un match qui s'annonce serré les trappes
y sont actuellement 5e du championnat à
un point seulement de leurs adversaires
qui classait à 3e en cas de victoire
trappe pourrait se retrouver en tête du
championnat de nationale 3 au milieu de
la saison ce week-end ce sera également
le téléthon plusieurs animations
sportives seront organisées samedi et
dimanche dans les yvelines pour récolter
des fonds à saint-cyr-l'ecole le cubain
andy cabreira avila que vous voyez à
l'écran va tenter de battre un nouveau
record d'apnée d'endurance sociaux 24
heures à l'appel et la piscine aqua
mundo
son objectif est de réaliser 40 de
kilomètres en une journée sous l'eau en
faisant des longues heures l'équivalent
d'un marathon
le départ sera donné ce samedi à 11
heures l'ensemble des profits récoltés
pendant l'opération sera reversée au
téléthon
on termine ce magazine sportif par une
très belle histoire c'est la d'alain à
crampons cette habitante bois d'arcy âgé
de 70 ans va partir ce vendredi 8
décembre avec son vélo et sa remorque
pour faire un tour de cuba pendant deux
mois
au total ils devraient parcourir environ
2000 km pendant son parcours pour
réaliser cet exploit ils s'entraînent
dans les forêts des yvelines deux à
trois fois par semaine une routine pour
ce senior qui a déjà réalisé des
périples au portugal en france ou encore
au canada pour l'écouter il était au
micro de tv 78 de toute façon c'est de
la randonnée c'est de la promenade donc
il n'y a pas d'urgence
si on a un peu mal aux fesses au début
parce que ça peut arriver
ben on fait moins de kilomètres la
moyenne ces 15 km heure de moyenne c'est
que dalle donc 15 km heure pour regarder
la nature
c'est fabuleux et en plus on avance
parce que trois heures le matin et puis
de trois heures l'après-midi ben on a
fait 60 70 km c'est simple c'est simple
comme un coup de
c'est tout ça et surtout va je vous ai
vu à réagir à l'interview de ce papy qui
va réaliser le tour de cuba
c'est joli c'est bien mais sans en
pensez vous
en vo et l'autre avec une balle de foot
dans les pieds cette dernière est bien
sûr surtout à son âge mais voilà après
s'il a toujours fait du sport
c'est ça faire du sport ça garde la la
santé c'est une bonne chose chose même
chose même chose pour vous c'est un beau
projet quoi ça vos projets ça sera le
mot de la fin c'est la fin de cette
fuite sport merci l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve le lundi lundi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro 10 il a passé une
excellente semaine sportive très bonne
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]